let us pray
almighty god
we give you thanks for this day even as
we give you thanks for life itself
we humbly acknowledge that you are the
source of all truth
and the author of all wisdom
as we gather in your sight for this
164th commencement
ceremony we give you thanks not only for
the young men and women
who now transition to the next phase of
their lives
but also for all those who make
hillsdale college
center of sound learning that it is
we thank you for the inspirational
mentors
who are such a blessing to all the lives
they touch
and those behind the scenes
who empower the good
and project the beautiful
especially this day we remember with
thanks
professor don turner
who continues to be gravely ill
and professor
olga
muniz
who has departed this life
as well as our longtime trustee
mrs hazel hair
also departed
bless and comfort both the sick
and those who mourn
we now ask your special blessing on this
class
of 2016.
bless them
bless their families
and bless their friends now and in the
future
continue to bless this college
that it may always be an effective
instrument in the pursuit of truth
and the defense of
freedom all this we pray in the most
holy name of your son
our lord and savior
jesus christ
amen
please join us in the pledge of
allegiance
i pledge
it allegiance one nation
under god
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
you may be seated
thank you for coming
my name is larry yarn i'm the president
of the college
i apologize for standing in the cold
this is the largest audience we've ever
had at commencement
and the reasons for that are obvious
this is the greatest senior class we
ever had
actually it is tied for the largest
senior class we ever had and it has some
qualities and i'm going to name a couple
and of course it might have something to
do with the presence of the very great
man who sits behind me
and the provost is a great man too but i
didn't mean him
i know that you all came here to hear me
talk a long time and um so i do have
four things i have to do
uh i have to state the purpose of the
ceremony
i have to recognize
two groups and three groups and one
great man
i'll do that as fast as i can and i mean
them profound respect
the ceremony is to carry on and exhibit
the purpose of the college
the purpose of the college is the
activity of knowledge
you may think that's a possession but it
is not
it is people together thinking talking
learning and keeping what they know
alive
it is actually the highest human
activity
the founding of our college
gives rise to that purpose
as with the purposes age old much older
than the college
and this ceremony has been held in this
place on this campus
since before the civil war but the
ceremony itself in its form is age old
and our founding document mentions four
benefits of this
activity these benefits include us all
first and foremost the benefit of the
activity is the activity itself
it is joyful to learn
and it makes you a better human being
we are made for that more than anything
else and that is a specific way
we become like our maker and the most
excellent thing we can possibly be
then there's freedom
the learned soul cannot be a good slave
that was said that print that phrase
in the dedication of central hall on
this campus by our second president a
friend of abraham lincoln
when it was dedicated
and we here love civil and religious
freedom and devoted to it and we love
the declaration of independence and the
constitution of the united states which
name and protect that better than any
documents in human history
then there is the improvement of
character
because unless we are brave and moderate
and just
we cannot learn and we cannot live well
and then finally there is our connection
with god which we here at hillsdale
college have worshipped through the
christian faith
from the beginning and will continue
always with the respect of the right of
everyone to worship
as he pleases
today in the world a tide is running
against this
this is what colleges always did not so
much anymore
we stand against this tide
the pressures are great and growing all
the time
but we have studied history and we know
that we are not the first to have to do
that and we will not be the last
and so i promise that we mean to hold to
our station and this commitment
commencement is intended to increase our
resolve to do that
thank you for joining us to do that
i ask you to make the same resolve
the first group i must mention is of
course the seniors
today they stand for the whole college
they are a splendid senior class
and what they have done they have done
as well as any in our history
they came here 388 strong
there are 353 of them down there
that's not quite the same thing as
graduation rate but it's above 90
percent and it indicates that the
graduation rate is going that way toward
90 percent
and of course these seniors have been
through the
hell that hillsdale college imposes on
all its students
and they live to smile and tell the tale
some of them have one particular
distinction
for example our salutatorian
is a jack shannon
student of mine
very smart
a young man a very high character worked
in my office for three years
and i can tell you as a badge of honor
to our faculty who i'm going to mention
a minute that he has made all a's except
a minuses from bursar jackson
and a private piano class
i hereby honor berzer jackson and the
piano teacher
our valedictorian is sarah unken
she's from indiana she's a politics and
math major jack's going to the london
school of economics by the way
and uh and uh sarah is going to go to
our graduate school living and graduate
school statesmanship to get a phd
and she has her only a minus from the
greatly honored today
lorraine
edie but for that she would have had her
four point which we don't like around
here
so i congratulate lorraine
would
jack and sarah and the other top ten
graduates please stand
looks like three boys which is more than
normal
and uh
their names of the top ten are in your
program
now two have been chosen outstanding by
a process that involves the whole campus
and i'm going to name them in descending
order
the outstanding senior woman is marie
wathen
she's also queen of the president's ball
she's a lovely young woman and she's
going to go to work in boise idaho
choosing to save the country from the
middle
and the outstanding senior man remember
i'm going down
is a
matthew sauer
who i have had in class along with
shannon over there and
you know that boy is not as dumb as he
looks
and he majors in history
and we have given him a a job at the
college
what were we thinking
would you two please stand up
the class features the best shotgun
shooter in the in the in the in the
country and a faf three times on a
national championship team
the best middle distance runner in the
country emily oren
we have our first winning baseball team
in 25 years
and
and they are not here today because
they're playing in the conference second
second round of the conference
tournament and we haven't been there
since as my mother used to say hector
was a pup
our softball team the coach at the
softball team and the baseball team have
been named coach of the year
kyle cooper
who's a really fine young man and top
student is an all-conference basketball
player and of course we have way the
most in this very difficult school who
are on the athletic academic hall of
fame or national all americans
so you'd think that they're just a bunch
of jocks here in front of me
but i'll tell you two other things about
them that are really interesting one of
them is
you know accreditation has become this
terribly bureaucratic thing that's very
dangerous to the college
it's actually a republican idea to make
it so
but the democrats take to things like
that very fast themselves
and uh so we have to now show that the
students have learned
and when we reply well you know we do
give them grades and talk to them and
stuff we might know whether they learned
or not no that won't do
you have to find some outside measure to
prove that what you say about whether
they've learned or not is true
and so this year the provost or somebody
found that the educational testing
service which does the mcat and the gre
and the lsat
gives a proficiency exam for seniors
and these this senior class has taken it
for the first time in hillsdale college
history there
close to 300 colleges that take it it
took it this year
and uh i won't say that we chose them by
random sample and i won't say that we
got volunteers because how are you going
to get a senior to sit and take a
three-hour exam or however long it was
so we gave them 25 amazon gift
certificates
now
the grade point average of the ones who
took it
is exactly like the grade point average
of the rest of them sitting there
and so i know that our standards are not
impressive to the outside world but they
are to us and it means that the ones who
took it are just like the rest of them
and this exam comes in seven categories
and the nine percent of the senior class
who took that made in the 99th
percentile in three of them
and they made the best score in the
country in the other four
and the ones who didn't make the best
score on the country on the three they
were very close but still we're putting
a demerit on their diploma
and i want you to understand that these
students are young are young still
although they're kind of grown up now
and i want to give them this honor
this is the first senior class
members of whom
threw an ice cream cone on my table in
the dining hall during lunch
from the upper floor
would colin wilson stand up please
okay colin sit down shut up
and he and his
co-conspirators finally fessed up and
came forward put on a tie and apologized
to be in my office and their punishment
is they are responsible if that ever
happens again and it is not
and they didn't get any ice cream on me
which i think means it was a good shot
i never saw better than this
i uh honor and respect them
and ask them to stand so you may do so
too
you'll be missed but you're oh uh this
senior
class has given us money as a higher
percentage of the number of them than
any class in history thank you for that
and don't go away
you're still part of the college you
never get rid of that so we won't miss
you we're still going to know you
now
there are two groups of people
outside themselves and god who are the
main agents in making them what they are
who have had
decisive impacts on them
and the first of course is their parents
i want you to know that we understand
what you're thinking today we're parents
ourselves and we do this for a living
we know that you're relieved and proud
because they've grown up and you've done
your stuff
you must be thinking you know we've won
we've run the race now
this has been hard
in fact if known how hard maybe we
wouldn't have done it
but then also you're thinking
this has been the first purpose of my
life now for 21 years
what am i going to do now
that part's over
where is that child that we watched
tuttle off to
preschool
what became of that
i want you to know that that's sad and
we know that it's sad
we feel that loss too because they're
going from us as well
but i can comfort you because my wife
penny and i have four children and
they're grown now
and the comfort i'll give you is that
they will still call for help all the
time
and you will be able to know the kind of
help they want
by whom they wish to speak to
my wife is good at everything i'm good
at money and heart duty
so if it's if it's me they want they're
broke or else something that they think
is terrible has happened if it's mom it
could be anything
i want to thank you parents i dare say
we have the best relationship with
parents here
ever
parents weekend is a joy
your partnership with us in the
education of your children
has been simply necessary to it of
course what you did for 18 years before
but also during these four
so i ask you with my great thanks and
all of the college pleased to stand and
be recognized
the second group is the faculty
they are in measurable ways
among the few finest in the land
some of them have won
many of them have won great distinction
this year i'm going to name three
every year at convocation twice a year
we give an award for teaching excellence
chosen by their peers and the students
and it goes one term to a junior and the
other term to a senior faculty member
and this year the winners of barbara
bushey and art and matt guytano in
history would they stand up please
we have a professor of the year every
year and this year someone has won it
for the fourth time which is the most in
history
if he didn't like the san francisco
giants and bailey's irish cream he would
be a perfect faculty member
tom connor would you stand up please
we have several retirees and they're
going to miss them greatly
they are
maria rebear
32 years teaching french robert eden 29
years teaching politics john fennell
dean of the social sciences and director
of teacher education
13 years
mentioned in prayer where don turner
who's very ill 18 years in philosophy
and the lately and much mourned departed
olga muniz
who was here for 23 years and we give
special condolences to her husband kevin
teegarden who teaches spanish here
and would those retirees stand up please
the faculty as a whole as i say
you just understand what they are
they have deep
education
in highly learned things
way beyond what any normal person knows
they don't make so much money
they have a devotion to the young to
pass that learning on and of course that
is a massive act of kindness
they are
irreplaceable and great
please stand faculty
we have with us today an associate
justice of the supreme court of the
united states
you may read his biography in your
program
you will see in it that he was born in
pinpoint georgia
south of savannah and a shanty without a
bathroom or electricity except light in
the kitchen
you will see that he is a proximate
descendant of slaves
he was raised by his grandparents
myers and christine anderson his mother
being unable to manage it financially
you must read his book my grandfather's
son which is an inspiration
he will read that the justice attended
pius the 10th high school in savannah
georgia from 1962 to 64 9th and 10th
grades
and i will tell you now that hillsdale
college is proud of its 13 childhood
charter schools
and that one of those in savannah
georgia operates in that building where
justice thomas went for two years
and the eighth grade of that school is
here with us today
along with their great headmaster ben
payne
several members of their staff one of
them hillsdale graduate kayla fletcher
formerly cash
mr payne has forbidden me to ask these
students to stand for reasons that may
be good
but it turns out it's necessary for me
to ask them to stand because yesterday
almost all of them committed to attend
to hillsdale college
and i want the admissions office to see
who they are stand up savannah classical
wherever you are
justice thomas was a brilliant student
but these guys might be better
i've been privileged to know the justice
since 1987.
i formed the view early that he is the
greatest public servant i know
when i became president of the college
chairman broadback asked me who i'd like
to speak at my inauguration ceremonies
and i replied that i of course hoped it
would be this greatest man
and he did that for me
and i'm grateful to him
honored beyond any telling
honored beyond any telling his being
here today
there are two reasons i believe of him
as i do
the first is the quality of his work
i took to reading his opinions after he
got on the court i had been reading
everything he wrote
before that
one finds in them a great act of
recovery
he reads the constitution both
originally and profoundly
he sees in it the structure that
provides the form
in which the american people can pursue
their purposes
he understands that it is their document
that they passed it and that is the only
law that they have ever passed
he sees that it must remain constant if
it is to remain their own
he says that if you read it
intelligently you must you have the duty
to get the rights and the justice of
each case right according to the details
but also you must understand its large
purposes which culminate i will say
according to the people who wrote it
and the purposes i named as the purposes
of this college that is that each one of
us
may govern himself
and his country so as to live a fully
human life
there is in these opinions a beautiful
history of american law
and a treasure of civilization and
freedom
and these are large claims and i do not
have time to prove them but if you write
me a letter i will send you the opinions
that do prove them
the second is his character
he is a man deeply moved by his loves
and they are the right loves
he loves freedom and equality
he finds them what the in them what the
best americans have found a challenge to
live well
to face one's fears to build one's
character to develop one's mind
i have seen him demonstrate this on so
many occasions i cannot count
and i stand in awe of them
he is i think
the kind of man is the greatest visitor
to our college in the 19th century
i mean the runaway slave frederick
douglass
that man like our speaker today was
mistreated and abused because of the
color of his skin of course douglas more
severely than thomas but not more
severely than thomas's ancestors
but the reaction of douglas to this
abuse was to love the principles and
institutions of our country which
condemn the abuse that he received
because they proclaimed the wrong of
that abuse
and because they offer the hope that no
one may suffer that abuse
the response of justice thomas to harm
is to preach good
good for all
good for all the same
it is the attitude
of the great soul man of the magnanimous
man
and it shows itself all the time
and seeking to honor this man which we
all come here to do today
of course it is rather we who are
honored
please welcome associate justice of the
supreme court clarence thomas
thank you all
thank you
thank you
thank you
thank you all
dr arn
chairman broadbank
members of the board
members of the faculty
family friends
most of all graduates
i'm honored to be here
i'm particularly honored because my
bride is with me
and we spend quite a bit of time
together
and we like i think to have memories
together and this is indeed is a memory
again i'd like to thank dr aren for
inviting me
and again i express my deep honor and
gratitude to participate
in these commencement exercises
it's been quite some years since
virginia and i
have been here together
we've been here on separate occasions
but rarely together
of course we have known dr larry and
mrs arn penny yarn for many many years
as dr arn has indicated
and we have been quite close to
hillsdale
throughout his tenure
we both admire the work that is being
done here to educate young men and young
women
i was fortunate to
have had david morrell
a hillsdale graduate clerked for me a
few years back
he was an outstanding law clerk and a
wonderful brilliant young man
he's also
one of my daily mass
companions
i also had a chance last evening as dr
arn mentioned
to visit with the young students who
attend savannah classical academy in my
hometown of savannah georgia what a
wonderful idea
and as dr aaron indicated this is the
very same school that i attended high
school in in the 1960s
this has been a most difficult term at
the court
this difficulty
is underscored by the sudden
and tragic passing of my colleague and
friend justice antonin scalia
i think it is fitting to say a few words
about him particularly here
many will focus on his intellect and his
legal prowess
i do not demure in either case
but there is so much more to the man
than that
when i think of justice scalia
i think of the good man whom i could
instinctively trust
during my first days on the court and
those were challenging days
he was in the tradition of the south of
my youth
a man of his word
a man of character
over the almost 25 years that we were
together
i think
we made the court a better place for
each other
i certainly know that he made it a
better place for me
he was kind to me when it mattered most
in those early days
he is
and will be sorely missed
as the years since i attended college
edged toward a half century
i feel a bit out of place talking with
college students or recent graduates
much it's must
much has changed since i left college in
nineteen seventy one
things that were once considered firm
long since lost their vitality
and much that seemed inconceivable
is now firmly or universally established
hallmarks of my youth
such as patriotism and religion
seem more like outliers
if not afterthoughts
so in a sense
i feel woefully out of place doing this
or any commencement
my words will perhaps be perhaps be more
of a vintage nature than currently in
content
than current in content
words actually matter
not a current newspeak
i admit to being unapologetically
catholic
unapologetically patriotic
and
unapologetically a constitutionalist
in my youth we had a small farm
i am convinced
that the time i spent there
had much to do with my firm resolve
to never never farm again
work seemed to spring eternal
like the weeds that consumed so much of
our time and our lives and our efforts
one of the constantly conveyed messages
was our obligation to take care of the
land
and to use it to produce food for
ourselves and for others
if there was to be independence
self-sufficiency or freedom
then we had to first understand
accept
and then discharged
our responsibilities
the latter were the necessary but not
always sufficient
antecedents or precursors of the former
the only guarantee was that if you did
not discharge your responsibilities
there could be no independence
no self-sufficiency
no freedom
no crops
in a broader context
we were obligated in our neighborhood
to be good neighbors so that the
neighborhood would thrive
whether there was to be a clean thriving
neighborhood
was directly connected to our efforts
and to our conduct
so
there was always to our way of thinking
a connection and a relationship
between the things we valued most and
our personal obligations or efforts
there could be no freedom without each
of us discharging our responsibilities
that was first and foremost
in that context
when we heard the words
duty honor country
no more needed to be said
but that is a bygone era
today we
rarely hear of our personal
responsibilities
in discussions of broad notions
such as freedom or liberty
it is as though freedom and liberty
exists
wholly independent of anything we do
seemingly it is our version of
predestination
or as my grandfather often warned us
or
told us money didn't grow on trees
perhaps we think liberty grows on trees
their existence
initial
and continuing
is independent of our conduct
in fact
this era is one in which any difference
or different treatment is inherently
suspect
apparently we all deserve the same
reward
the same status
notwithstanding the differences in our
efforts or our abilities
it is no wonder then that we hear so
often what is deserved
or to what one is entitled
i guess by this reasoning
the student who took full advantage of
all the spring break
bacchanalia
is apparently entitled to the same
success
as a conscientious disciplined classmate
who worked and studied while he played
perhaps
we should redistribute the conscientious
students grades
to make the frolicking classmate his or
her equal
i'm sure the top 10 students would love
that
this leads me to wonder
if the same sense of entitlement applies
to
that which makes it possible for us to
live in a free country
after the constitutional convention in
philadelphia
benjamin franklin remarked when asked
what they had done
that they had given us a republic
if we can keep it
nearly a century later
in his two-minute speech at gettysburg
president lincoln again spoke of what
was required of us after the battle of
gettysburg
he said
it is rather for us to be here dedicated
to the great task remaining before us
that from these honored dead
we take increased devotion to that cause
for which they gave the last full
measure
that we here highly resolve
that these dead shall not have died in
vain
that this nation under god
shall not have shall have a new birth of
freedom
and that government of the people by the
people for the people shall not perish
from the earth
many who have gone before us
have done precisely that
they have been dedicated to the
preserving and enhancing our nation
and the liberties upon which it is built
in war and in peace
they have made sure that those who gave
the last full measure
did not do so in vain
because you all are graduates of
hillsdale college
it is quite appropriate and quite
convenient
to reflect briefly
on their understanding of what was to be
preserved
what what what had to be earned
the founders and many successive
generations
believed in natural rights
and that
as the declaration of independence makes
clear
to establish a government by consent
they gave up only those rights
necessary to create a limited government
they then structured that government so
that it could not jeopardize the liberty
that flowed from these inherent or
natural rights
of course these limitations have roots
that go as far back
as the original magna carta over 800
years ago
but even though this liberty is inherent
it is neither guaranteed nor assured
the very founding documents of our
country for example
are an assertion of this liberty
against arguably the most powerful man
in the world
and it was secured at the risk
of the lives fortunes
and sacred honor of those who dare to
assert that liberty
over the lifespan of our great country
occasions have arisen
that requ that have have arisen
that required this liberty
as well as the form of government that
ensures it
be defended if it was to survive
at the risk of understating what it is
necessary to preserve liberty and our
form of government
i think more and more that it depends on
good citizens discharging their daily
duties and their daily obligations
i resist what seems to be somewhat
formulaic
or standard fare at commencement
exercises
some broad complaint about societal
injustice and at least one exhortation
to the young graduates to go out and
solve the stated problem or otherwise to
change the world
having been where you all are
i think it is hard enough to first solve
your own problems
not to mention those problems
that often seem to devout to fi defy
solution
in addressing your own obligations and
responsibilities
in the right way
you actually help to ensure our
liberties and our form of government
throughout my youth even as the
contradictions of segregation persisted
we revered the ideals of our great
nation
of course we knew that our country was
like all human institutions a flawed
nation
but we also knew that
in the ideal of liberty
lay our last best hope
i watched with anguish
as so many of the older people in my
life
groped and stumbled through the darkness
of illiteracy or bare literacy
yet
they desperately wanted to know to learn
they implicitly knew how important it
was to enjoy the fullness of citizenship
of this great country
they had spent an aggregation of
lifetimes
standing on the edge of that dual
citizenship
that is at the heart of the 14th
amendment of our constitution
and even during the last world war
they were willing to fight for the right
to die on foreign soil to defend their
country
even as their patriotic affections went
unreciprocated or unrequited
they returned from that horrific war
with dignity to face the indignity of
discrimination at home
yet
the desire to push our nation
to live up to its stated ideals
persisted
i often wondered why my grandparents
remained
such model citizens
even when our country's failures were so
obvious
in the arrogance of my early adult life
i challenged my grandfather and doubted
the ideals of our nation
he bluntly asked
so
where else would you live
though not a lettered man
he knew
that though not nearly perfect
our constitutional ideals were
perfectable
if we worked to protect them
rather than to undermine them
as he said
son
don't throw the baby out with the bath
water
that is
don't discard that which is precious
along with that which is tainted
sadly
today when it seems that
grievances rather than personal conduct
are the means of elevation
this may sound odd or at least
discordant
but those around
but those around us back then
seemed to have resolved
to conduct themselves consistent with
the duties that the ideals of our
country demanded
they were law abiding
hard working
disciplined
they discharged their responsibilities
to their families and neighbors as best
they could
we were taught that despite unfair
treatment
we were to be good citizens
and good people
if we were to have a functioning
neighborhood
then
we had to first be good neighbors
and if
we were to have a good city
state and country
we had to first be
good citizens
the same went for our school and our
church
the corporal works of mercy
the greatest commandment
love thy neighbor as thyself
just because someone else wronged us
did not justify reciprocal conduct on
our part
right was right
and two wrongs did not make a right
as my grandfather often said
we were duty bound to do the right thing
to do unto others as we would have them
do unto us
in a sense
they were teaching us
that what we wanted to do
did not define what was right
nor am i then
did our capacious litany of once defined
liberty
rather
what was right
defined
what we were required to do
and what we were permitted to do
it defined our duties and our
responsibilities
whether those duties meant cutting our
neighbor's lawn
visiting the sick
feeding the hungry
or in rare cases going off to war as my
brother did
we were honorably we were to honorably
discharge them
shortly before his death in 1983
i sought my grandfather's advice
about how to weather
the first wave of criticism directed
toward me
i admit to having been somewhat unnerved
back then
by the torrent of negativity
he immediate his immediate response was
simple
son
you have to stand up for what you
believe in
to him
that was my obligation and my duty
perhaps
it is at times like that
when you lack both strength and courage
that the clarity of our obligation
supplies both
duty honor country
the clarity of obligation
as i admitted at the outset
i am of a different time
i knew no one for
example who was surprised when
president john f kim kennedy famously
said
at his inauguration in 1961
ask not what your country can do for you
but what you can do for your country
that sentiment was as common as saying
the pledge of allegiance
and singing the star spangled banner
and as pervasive as shopping at army
navy surplus stores
today of course
there is much more focus on our rights
as citizens and what we are owed
it is not often that one hears of our
obligations or our duties as citizens
unless of course there's talk of our
duty
to submit to yet another new policy
being suggested or proposed
my grandfather often said that
if we didn't work we didn't eat
or if we didn't plant we didn't harvest
there was to always be a relationship as
i said earlier between our
responsibilities and our benefits
in agrarian societies
that is more obvious
as society becomes more complex and
specialized
this is more difficult to discern
but let's look at it look at this a
different way
if you continue to run up charges on
your credit card
and never make a payment
at some point you reach your credit
limit
if you continue to make withdrawals from
your savings account
and make no deposits
eventually you deplete your funds
why is it not the case then
that if we continue
to consume the benefits of a free
society
without replenishing or nourishing it
we will eventually deplete it
if we are not making deposits to
replenish our liberties
then who is
are we content to let others do the work
to let a few
give the last full measure for liberty
while we consume the benefits
if so
perhaps one day
we will run out of other people's
sacrifice and courage
and perhaps
we will run out of courageous people
willing to make the sacrifice
but
this is hillsdale college
and you are special
that shining city on a hill
hillsdale is a trustee
of the heritage that finds its clearest
expression
in the american experiment of
self-government under law
the very existence of hillsdale connotes
independence
it understands that liberty
is an antecedent of government
not a benefit from government
i offer you graduates a few brief
suggestions to make your contributions
to liberty
your deposits to the account of liberty
today is just the end of the beginning
of your young
lives and
it is the beginning
the commencement of the rest of your
lives
and hopefully
their long fruitful lives in a free
country
there is much more to come and it will
not be with the guiding hands of your
parents
perhaps your hand will be required to
guide them
indeed some of you
will
most assuredly be called upon to do the
very hard things to preserve liberty
perhaps even give the last full measure
but all of you
will be called upon to provide that firm
foundation of citizenship
by carrying out your obligations in much
the way that those around you did
and so many did during my youth
you are to be the example to others
that they were to you
the greatest lecture or sermon you will
give
is your example
what you do
will matter far more than what you say
as the years have swiftly moved by
i have often reflected on the importance
citizenship lessons of my life
for the most part
it was the unplanned array of small
things
there was a kind gesture from the
neighbor
it was my grandmother dividing our
dinner
because another person showed up
unannounced
it was the strangers
stopping to help us get our crops out of
the field before a big storm
there were the irish nuns
who believed in us
and lived in our neighborhood
there was the librarian
who brought books to mass so that i
would not be without reading materials
on the farm
small lessons such as these
became big lessons for how to live our
lives
we watched and learned what it means to
be a good person
a good neighbor
or a good citizen
who will be watching you
and what will you be teaching them
after this commencement
i implore you
to take a few minutes
to thank those who made it possible for
you to come this far
your parents your teachers
your pastor your coaches
you know who helped you
take a few minutes to show your
gratitude
these are the people
who have shown you how to sacrifice
for those whom they love
even when that sacrifice is not always
appreciated
as you go through life
try to be that person
whose actions teach others how to be
better
people and better citizens
reach out to that shy person
who's not so popular
stand up for others when they're being
treated unfairly in small things and
large
take the time to listen to that friend
who's having a difficult time
do not hide your faith and your beliefs
under a bushel basket
especially
in this world that seems to have gone
mad with political correctness
treat others the way you would like to
be treated
if you stood in their shoes
these small lessons become
the unplanned syllabus
for becoming a good citizen
and your efforts to live them
will help to form the fabric of a civil
society
and a free and prosperous nation
where inherent equality
and liberty are inviolable
you are men and women of hillsdale
college
a school that has stood fast on its
principles and its traditions at great
sacrifice and great cause
you are men and women of hillsdales
steeped in the best traditions and
principles
of our great nation
if you don't lead by example who will
i have every faith that
you will be the beacon of light for
others to follow
that city on a hill that cannot be
hidden
may god bless each of you now and
throughout your lives
and may god bless america thank you
probably knew it already but see what i
mean
never never saw the like
just as time as we come forward please
on behalf of the faculty and board of
trustees of hillsdale college
it is my privilege to present to you
clarence thomas the honorary degree
doctor of laws
i graduated
peter plotkin was born in dallas and
moved to los angeles
served in the army air corps during
world war ii worked for hughes aircraft
designing missiles and stuff
in the 60s he began his career in
development he built 35 apartment
buildings
near los angeles international airport
with his brother maury he has
established the peter and marsha plotkin
memorial foundation in honor of his
parents
his father was an immigrant and a
well-known and accomplished painter
many in large paintings full of
religious and patriotic themes i have
seen them
and peter cherishes them and displays
them with pride in a large building he
keeps for the purpose
he has two children pamela and paul
his wife diane was born in syracuse
she's worked for an abc affiliate she's
done just about everything there is to
do including lots of charity for a
children's home and many other things
she has two sons ian and clayton
and three granddaughters
they met at a philanthropy round table
in 2000.
you will see that diane is a beautiful
woman when she comes up here
and she loves peter they're both
widowed and having a second marriage
and she says she's gonna keep him alive
for a long time
and when she says that peter replies
that he doesn't want to be
live long enough to be married to an old
woman
diane and peter will you come forward
please
thank you
thank you
be over
on behalf of the faculty of hillsdale
college and the authority invested in me
by its board of trustees
it is my privilege to present to peter
and diane plotkin the honorary degree
doctor of public service
thank you very much
they have been kind to pills out of
college and
kind to me and to john cerrini on many
occasions
janet p wonka brought back
grew up in shaker heights ohio
she graduated from hillsdale college in
1967 she was a kappa
all the blondes or campus i guess
she married bill broadback in
1967 and there she began her term of
penance that leads to this degree
they moved to uh
they were in the grocery business in
wisconsin
builds a wisconsin native
and bill's of course the chairman of our
board
she has served as chairman of the board
for a hospital in platteville wisconsin
where they lived a long time and for
various other charities there they have
three beautiful daughters
and i will say personally of janet p
wonka broadback i often call her biwonka
because i really like that last name
that she's one of the kindest most
cheerful most persistent people
and she has been a support to bill who
has been a support to me
so it'd be wrong for me to have two
wives but if i if i did i'd want her
janet would you come forward please
she just called me shameful
see
see see what i mean
on behalf of the faculty of hillsdale
college and with the authority invested
in me by its board of trustees i present
to you janet p wonka broadvac
the honorary degree doctor of public
service
we have the best board in the country
we had a meeting yesterday and they put
up with me
and are such a help to me
and
led by the chairman bill broadback
no member of that board has been more
important for 30 years than hazel hare
who died in march
hazel is a resident of
phoenix she's a
graduate of brooklyn polytechnic
she was a researcher first for american
cyanomed and then for d.c hair dgc hair
john cevini knew her husband well he was
a great friend of the college
they married in 1957.
hazel contracted lou gehrig's disease
and in february she called me
and i can tell you nobody
likes
anybody better than hazel if they know
hazel and certainly nobody on our board
does
she chaired forever the academic and
student affairs committee and she looked
at the students of at the college like
children of her own
and she was always bringing up stuff
they needed
and often giving us that stuff
she's firm she's been on the prudential
or executive committee of the board ever
since i've been here
and i have found her firm in judgment
and patient
when she called me her voice was
affected by her disorder already of
which had been recently diagnosed and
she said she had this disease
and that she hadn't
she had to resign the board
and i said you must not
and she said
i can't even write you a letter
at this stage
and this board since my husband died has
been the chief purpose of my life
i have not been so touched in
by much of anything
she has a niece he's very close to her
uh
tracy kane is here with her husband bill
hazel helped to raise tracy
they were very close and tracy cared for
her
in her
illness which took her quickly
and we miss
hazel deeply and we are grateful to
tracy
please come forward
on behalf of the faculty of hillsdale
college and with the authority invested
in me by its board i bestow upon hazel
hare the honorary degree doctor of
public service
the senior class president is nicholas
brown
he comes from columbus he majored in
economics he did very well
shall i get well he didn't do as well as
say
sarah but
he did really well
and i get to read a sentence that i
don't know that i would ever read didn't
think i would ever read about a student
at hillsdale college he is president of
the entrepreneurship club club and he
does lots of volunteering and he's an
incredibly organized kid
but also he co-owned and operated i'm
just reading this because i can't
believe it
beechwood avenue limited a startup
clothing design firm that manufactured
and sold upscaled men's attire
and this lasted for a year and four
months
which means i guess it went bust after
that time
but isn't it like a dog walking on his
hind legs the miracle
the miracle was it was done at all
nick is among the senior class officers
who he's a very artful kid nick are you
walking up here start walking
so these kids came loaded for bear this
year
and it wasn't like the year morrell
graduated when they wanted chuck norris
clarence thomas has been in the fi top
five on the senior class list to be
commencement speaker for the 16 years
that i have been here
and i have never been willing to invite
him and the reason is i know how busy he
is
and i've always regarded it as an
imposition
and i
as you can tell i wish to be of service
to him rather than the other way around
so i've always told them no
but this year they showed up and waylon
helped them i think with the argument
that perhaps justice thomas is offended
that you have not asked him
now
that is sophism taken to a high pitch
can you imagine the poor justice sitting
there in his chambers in the supreme
court worrying whether i'm going to ask
him to come here and give a crap
and so i smiled when they said that and
i said okay that's pretty good i said i
will write that in the letter to him
and i did
so you all oh
we all owe
a very great debt to senior class
president nicholas brown
good afternoon
thank you to dr arn justice thomas
the rest of the platform party
faculty and staff
parents and friends
without you this wouldn't be the
celebration it ought to be
and to my fellow graduates
congratulations
i think we finally made hillsdale great
again
it truly is an honor to stand before you
today and i thank you for that
when i first visited hillsdale college
it was president's day
2012.
to celebrate winter brought the only
gift it could with one of the worst
blizzards the college had ever suffered
dr arn addressed those of us who had
come anyway
he said we put the college in michigan
because how would you get the work done
if you live somewhere warm
that struck me as a weird sales pitch
but we're yet it worked
now four years later
no one here needs a sales pitch for
hillsdale college
not at this point at least i hope not
but maybe we could benefit from one
final sales pitch for the liberal arts
a defense of what we just spent four
years doing
in our age western heritage has been
replaced with multicultural studies
and the honor code with political
correctness
and the confusion has gotten so bad
we don't even know where to go to the
bathroom
yet here
we continue to embrace the wisdom of the
past
today the liberal arts are under attack
and hillsdale college is the best
defense it could hope for
for weeks and months
as we approach this day
many have asked us the same question
what are you going to do
we've heard it all of our lives
what do you want to be when you grow up
it used to be possible and even cute to
say a basketball star
but among us the only person who can say
that without people laughing is kyle
cooper
the rest of us
need a better answer
now that i'm all grown up my answer is
to be an entrepreneur
and i can't think of a better
preparation for this
than the one the liberal arts has given
me
i've heard it said that entrepreneurship
is living a few years of your life
like most people won't
that you so that you can spend the rest
of your life like most people can't
and the same could be said
for the liberal arts our hillsdale
education has allowed us to live unlike
most other students
we've read the old books and engaged in
a dialogue which recognizes that the
answers are not easily found
we've come to better understand
ourselves and we've undertaken a
profound inquiry
what we've done
is at its core entrepreneurial
few of my classmates wouldn't consider
themselves entrepreneurs yet for all of
us the last four years
have been an entrepreneurial pursuit
as we questioned analyzed and searched
the word entrepreneur comes from a 13th
century french verb entrepreneur
meaning to do something or to undertake
in dr steele's history of economic
thought we learned that the first
academic use of the word was likely in
1730 by the economist richard cantelon
he identified the willingness to bear
the financial risk of a business venture
as the defining characteristic of an
entrepreneur
this willingness to bear is essential
for any successful entrepreneur but also
for the student of the liberal arts
for the last four years
we have struggled under the brilliance
of the great thinkers
the work which accompanied our pursuit
was hard
but the weight of the practice itself
was also silently present
whether we recognized it or not the
pursuit of the liberal arts presents
real danger to students
as we question our perceived reality
evaluating the mores which root us
we run the risk of being deceived by
sophistry
plato's protagoras might be helpful here
partly because i'm still trying to
impress dr arne
but mostly because plato says something
worth knowing
for i tell you there is far more serious
risk in the purchase of doctrines than
than that of edibles when you buy
vittles and liquors you can take the
advice of an expert as to what is fit to
eat or drink and what is not
but you cannot carry away doctrines in a
separate vessel you were compelled when
you handed over the price to take the
doctrine in your very soul by learning
it and so to depart either an injured or
a benefited man
the kind of education we have embraced
has been rigorous
unrelenting and even incendiary
pursued in solitude
it had the potential to consume us and
to leave us the slaves of deceptive
ideologies
done correctly it required a partnership
to sift through the appeals of the great
thinkers
as we question the legitimacy of their
claims
in cooperation we chose to bear the
burden of the liberal arts because of
all the questions it compels us to ask
cantolon shows us that both
entrepreneurship and the liberal arts
are inherently risky
yet another economist suggests the
passion for discovery moves both the
entrepreneur
and the student to embrace this risk
for israel kersner entrepreneurial
discovery gradually but systematically
pushes back the boundaries of sheer
ignorance
just as the entrepreneur dissolves his
ignorance in the discovery of hidden
opportunities
our embrace of the liberal arts erases
our ignorance driving us ever closer to
a knowledge of the truth
at college we grappled with the nature
of man his purpose
and his role in the governance of our
society
we examined the concept of justice and
what it looked like rightly applied
we questioned the efficacy of our modern
world
and we asked for advice from the
greatest thinkers of our heritage
in that rare instance what we thought we
knew was proven true
though more often in a moment of
disbelief our assumptions were exposed
to be woefully inadequate
for kirzner that surprise which
accompanies the realization that one has
overlooked something in fact readily
available
defines entrepreneurial discovery
and it also encapsulates the liberal
arts
when viewed as an act of
entrepreneurship our education begins as
an embrace of introspection aimed
towards discovery
and culminates in an unexpected moment
of awareness
in this moment
when our ignorance is found only to
disappear
entrepreneurship and the liberal arts
arrive at their greatest potential
no longer is either practice solitary
but instead the focus now turns outward
as the bible says in galatians 5 13
you my brothers and sisters were called
to be free
but do not use your freedom to indulge
the flesh
rather serve one another humbly in love
to some
entrepreneurship and the liberal arts
seem like selfish acts
the entrepreneur innovates for profit
and the student seeks after knowledge
but in these individual pursuits
something amazing happens
when the discovery of opportunity is
followed by action we begin to serve
others
for the entrepreneur to profit he must
innovate
creating a solution to the problem he's
encountered
he puts his discovered knowledge to work
by improving the lives of others
and the student of the liberal arts can
do the same
in our study of the good the true and
the beautiful
we have inherited a unique opportunity
to apply our discovery to the pursuit of
our life
in everything that we do
if we embrace the liberal arts as our
guideposts we become equipped to lead
those who are lost
the education then which is truly
enlightened is not content
simply to contemplate but rather aims to
put contemplation into practice
when we unite the revealed truth of the
liberal arts with our vocation
our education equips us for influence
and shakespeare's the tempest this one's
for you dr whalen
prospero serves as a warning to the one
who abandons his duty to others for a
zealous pursuit of the contemplative
life
i thus neglecting worldly ends all
dedicated to closeness and the bettering
of my mind with that witch but by being
so retired or prized all popular rape in
my false brother awakened an evil nature
and my trust like a good parent did
beget of him a falsehood in its contrary
as great as my trust was
which had indeed no limit
a confidence sands bound
prospero's selfish pursuit of knowledge
came with a cost
the abdication of his duty to rule
brought only hardship
leaving his nation exposed and his
family exiled
to pursue knowledge for itself can leave
one alone absent
and eventually insignificant
our education then was pursue knowledge
with an appeal to our greater purpose
economics has provided me with an
understanding of how the world works but
literature and humanities have shown us
what the world ought to be
the beauty of the liberal arts is found
in this dialogue between what is
and what could be
as we leave the seclusion of coffee
breaks at aj's
and lectures on monopoly markets
we must be reminded that there is work
to be done
the world increasingly embraces all that
is wrong
false and ugly
and we are among the lonely few who have
all the right questions
none of us made a mistake in embracing
the liberal arts to those who suggest
otherwise ask them
what is the good
my friends we can do that now
thank you
thank you nick good job
i want to thank my friend virginia
thomas who is a
fine wife to justice thomas and also an
urgent loving high-minded woman would
you stand please
well the graduating class of 2016 please
stand
upon the recommendation of the faculty
of hillsdale college and with the
authority vested in me by its board of
trustees
i confer upon each of you the degree for
which you have been a candidate
and admit you to all the rights
privileges and responsibilities
to which you are entitled and obliged
you are graduates now
congratulations
oh
when i
saw
is
is
my songs
our trees
oh
is
just
foreign
mountains
r
is
is
is
from
thank you chamber choir and james
holloman
and seniors i gave your degrees to you
out of order on the program and so you
have to start over as freshmen
professor smith will you proceed
will the graduates in accounting please
come forward
trevor anthony tidswell bachelor of
science accounting departmental honors
in accounting
yes
christian
michael
gager bachelor of arts and accounting
[ __ ] laude departmental honors and
accounting
justin john d'agostino bachelor of arts
accounting
megan brittany odin bachelor of science
accounting
tori lynn harris bachelor of arts
accounting summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and accounting
jordan scott baker bachelor of arts
accounting
kyle stephen cooper bachelor of arts
accounting summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in accounting
catherine k
bachelor of arts accounting
sarah l bessette bachelor of science
accounting [ __ ] laude departmental honors
in accounting
iona m kopp bachelor of science
accounting
christina lynn
chernowski bachelor of arts accounting
samuel carl holdeman bachelor of science
political economy and accounting
departmental honors political economy
curtis michael smith bachelor of science
accounting and financial management [ __ ]
laude departmental honors and accounting
and financial management
aaron patrick price bachelor of arts
accounting
will the graduates in american studies
please come forward
christian gage pinert bachelor of arts
american studies
nicholas theodore sacco bachelor of arts
american studies [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in american studies
jordan
jordan troy rimchisel bachelor of arts
american studies [ __ ] laude
adam christopher kern bachelor of arts
american studies in spanish magna [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in american
studies
michaela joy bennett bachelor of arts
american studies magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in american studies
anna louise path bachelor of arts
american studies in spanish magna [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in american
studies
will the graduates in biochemistry
please come forward
in art please come forward i'm going to
give you
benjamin steven strickland bachelor of
science arts and mathematics [ __ ] laude
tracy elizabeth brandt bachelor of arts
in art
megan sarah prom bachelor of arts art
heather
rochelle buell bachelor of arts art
jordan christian denmark bachelor of
arts art and spanish
patricia elizabeth clary bachelor of
arts in art magna [ __ ] laude
elizabeth deborah davis bachelor of arts
in art [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
art
faith maria lamb bachelor of arts in art
summa [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
art
will the graduates in biochemistry
please come forward
bachelor of science biochemistry magna
[ __ ]
corinne
laude
zainer bachelor of science biochemistry
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
biochemistry
bailey marie ray bachelor of science
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
ted robert march bachelor of science
biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
hannah mayland johnson bachelor of
science biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
perrin jean storch bachelor of science
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude bachelor
departmental honors in biochemistry
austin claire godley bachelor of arts
biochemistry
cadence a ribbons bachelor of science
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
zachary james nussbaum a bachelor of
science biochemistry
bethany
bethany lee mueller bachelor of science
biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
taylor carolyn wessel bachelor of
science biochemistry in history [ __ ]
laude
elizabeth hope
winia bachelor of science biochemistry
summa [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
biochemistry graduate of the honors
program
melissa a bott bachelor of science
biochemistry
naomi joy vernelson bachelor of science
biochemistry summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
olivia e jacquinet bachelor of science
biochemistry sumo [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biochemistry
haley k o'brien bachelor of science
biochemistry magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biochemistry
well the graduates in biology please
come forward
thank you
zoe marie noor bachelor of science
biology summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biology
eleanor guthrie smith bachelor of
science biology summa [ __ ] laude graduate
of the honors program
aaron william hess bachelor of science
biology [ __ ] laude
david william galgonitis bachelor of
science biology [ __ ] laude
andrea josefina
bachelor of arts biology
holly elizabeth frankford bachelor of
arts biology summa [ __ ] laude
catherine elise van egmen bachelor of
science biology summa [ __ ] laude
eric anders keela doll bachelor of
science biology
carly m hubbard bachelor of science
biology magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biology graduate of the honors
program
benjamin westbrook durrington bachelor
of science biology and french summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in biology and
french
cody joe broten bachelor of science
biology
michaela jane smith bachelor of science
biology [ __ ] laude departmental honors in
biology
sarah bell sparks bachelor of science
biology magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in
biology david john congdon bachelor of
science biology summa [ __ ] laude
matthew e mormon bachelor of science
biology summa [ __ ] laude
lauren schraeber bachelor of science
biology
julia catherine costco bachelor of
science biology
marissa ariel owen bachelor of science
biology summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biology
anna joy tolkien bachelor of science
biology summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in biology
kristin nicole torvinnen bachelor of
science biology
caitlin e remaster bachelor of science
biology [ __ ] laude
lindsey page lewis bachelor of science
biology [ __ ] laude
mary claire smith bachelor of science
biology
grace laura lee howe's bachelor of
science biology
mark david chamber bachelor of science
biology
benjamin rossing albers bachelor of
science biology and history [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in biology
emily patricia guy bachelor of science
biology
roger lee stewart bachelor of science
biology
daniel scott mumma bachelor of science
biology
alice montero cuccinelli bachelor of
science biology [ __ ] laude
william thomas fitch bachelor of science
biology
will the graduates in chemistry please
come forward
john mark becker bachelor of science
chemistry magna [ __ ] laude
joseph thomas banavets bachelor of
science chemistry [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in chemistry
andrew harrison baker bachelor of
science chemistry
yancey madison paul courtney
bachelor of science chemistry in english
[ __ ] laude
catherine alexandria royer bachelor of
science chemistry summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in chemistry
eric michael steger bachelor of science
chemistry
will the graduates in christian studies
please come forward
bailey elizabeth bergman bachelor of
arts christian studies summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and christian
studies
tears of patty shaw bachelor of arts
christian studies
hannah wolfe bachelor of arts christian
studies and political economy magna [ __ ]
laude departmental honors and political
economy
will the graduates in classical studies
please come forward
hannah m talkington bachelor of arts
greek in history kumar day
sydney manning sparks bachelor of arts
classics summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and classics
ilana gaynor bachelor of arts latin [ __ ]
laude
sarah madeleine brown bachelor of arts
english in latin
morgan rose bessmer bachelor of arts
latin
lindsay louise peterson bachelor of arts
latin
will the graduates in economics please
come forward
everett whitman ives bachelor of arts
economics and history
jeremy kenneth falar bachelor of science
economics
william jeffrey byrd bachelor of arts
economics
emily sue kendro bachelor of arts
economics summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in economics
rebecca may bowman bachelor of arts
economics [ __ ] laude departmental honors
and economics
daniel william david bachelor of arts
economics
colin stewart wilson bachelor of arts
economics [ __ ] laude departmental honors
and economics
kevin michael ambrose bachelor of arts
economics and politics
nicholas hall anderson bachelor of arts
economics
sylvia louise seeker bachelor of science
economics
grace elizabeth
van lanen bachelor of science economics
and mathematics summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in economics
emily ray albert bachelor of arts
economics magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and economics
anna catherine kucharski
bachelor of science economics
dana nicole trowbridge bachelor of arts
economics
ansly don brophy bachelor of arts
economics
ellen marine mcnally bachelor of arts
economics and spanish summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and economics
sydney jane delp bachelor of arts
economics
abby rose lovett bachelor of arts
international business and foreign
language and economics
alexandra savannah moines bachelor of
arts economics
jack b
shannon
jack benson shannon bachelor of arts
economics and latin summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors
in economics in latin graduate of the
honors program and class salutatorian
andrew chase swanson bachelor of arts
economics summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and economics
eric matthew walker bachelor of arts
economics magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and economics
mark david laprary bachelor of science
economics [ __ ] laude departmental honors
and economics
nicholas owen brown bachelor of arts
economics and politics magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and economics
david christopher fleming bachelor of
arts economics [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in economics
john david oxendine bachelor of arts
economics
gregory taylor summers bachelor of arts
economics
nolan patrick vordovich bachelor of
science economics magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and economics
alexander preston gregory mexico
bachelor of science economics
emily may oren bachelor of arts
economics cumulative departmental honors
in economics
will the graduates in english please
come forward
christina joy perkins bachelor of arts
english
claire faith lewis bachelor of arts
english [ __ ] laude
hannah elizabeth carroll bachelor of
arts english and spanish magna [ __ ] laude
catherine ann gietzen aguilera bachelor
of arts english
alan catherine morrison bachelor of arts
english
rebecca lee basinger sloanum bachelor of
arts english summa [ __ ] laude graduate of
the honors program
audrey lorena southgate bachelor of arts
english summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and english graduate of the
honors program
madison diane carney bachelor of arts
english and history [ __ ] laude
victoria nicole berry bachelor of arts
english summa [ __ ] laude
bethany nicole schuler bachelor of arts
english magna [ __ ] laude
jacqueline ariela frankel bachelor of
arts english magna [ __ ] laude
nicole
shuri cheney bachelor of arts english
[ __ ] laude
amanda joy tindall bachelor of arts
english
timothy john broxterman bachelor of arts
english
christopher john mccaffrey bachelor of
arts english
aaron james schreck bachelor of arts
english summa [ __ ] laude graduate of the
honors program
forester hodges mcclatchy bachelor of
arts art in english summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and art and graduate
of the honors program
congratulations
phoebe rebecca koltov bachelor of arts
english and art kumwade
megan lindsay andrews bachelor of arts
english [ __ ] laude
rachel may elizabeth hilly bachelor of
arts english
amanda caron gerke bachelor of arts
english
emma julia vinton bachelor of arts
english magna [ __ ] laude
madeline marie martinez bachelor of arts
english and spanish magna [ __ ] laude
megan elizabeth scott bachelor of arts
english honors program
minta rosalin ermer bachelor of arts
english magna [ __ ] laude
natalie christine mckee bachelor of arts
english summa [ __ ] laude
mary catherine meyer bachelor of arts
english summa [ __ ] laude
katrina therese kerwin bachelor of arts
english magna [ __ ] laude
kristen m dao bachelor of arts english
nafa rose knoll bachelor of arts english
summa [ __ ] laude
kimberly nicole adkins bachelor of arts
english
megan louise polston bachelor of arts
english
sarah elizabeth klopfer bachelor of arts
english magna [ __ ]
will the laude in exercise science
please come forward
amberly margaret bailey bachelor of
science exercise science magna [ __ ] laude
elise christine rempel bachelor of
science exercise science
lucia catherine rothus bachelor of
science exercise science
matthew james
hostrader bachelor of science exercise
science summa [ __ ] laude
alex d foate bachelor of science
exercise science magna [ __ ] laude
lucas a gross bachelor of science
exercise science
sarah josephine toyt bachelor of science
exercise science
kelsey lynn cromer bachelor of science
exercise science
kayla m geffert bachelor of science
exercise science [ __ ]
laude sarah elizabeth gruner
bachelor of science exercise science
magna [ __ ] laude
corinne marie wiggins bachelor of
science exercise
science
shannon elizabeth o'hearn bachelor of
science exercise science [ __ ] laude
will the graduates in financial
management please come forward
thank you
christopher john
boyajian bachelor of arts financial
management cumulative departmental man
honors and financial management
daniel joseph bullet bachelor of science
financial management
cole richmond service benzing bachelor
of arts financial management
patrick michael nolepa bachelor of arts
financial management cumulative
departmental honors and financial
management
ryan michael jalalian bachelor of arts
financial management magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and financial
management graduate of the honors
program
kelsey a lozer
bachelor of arts financial management in
spanish magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and financial management
alexis ann caruso bachelor of arts
financial management
paul douglas wendt bachelor of science
financial management departmental honors
and financial management
matthew joseph chalberg bachelor of
science computational mathematics and
financial management
robert joseph pfeiffer bachelor of arts
financial management
nicholas james shuster bachelor of
science financial management
einsley jordan
ellison
bachelor of arts financial management in
spanish magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in financial management
christian stoffel bachelor of arts
financial management magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and financial
management
jennifer ann wheeler bachelor of arts
financial management [ __ ] laude
seth aaron calico bachelor of science
financial management [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and financial
management
bennett thomas lewis bachelor of arts
financial management
edward martin
mollison bachelor of arts financial
management [ __ ] laude departmental honors
and financial management
william kelly albert bachelor of arts
financial management
wade owen wood bachelor of arts
financial management
christopher jeffrey mifsud
bachelor of arts financial management
keegan michael smith bachelor of science
financial management cumulative
departmental honors in financial
management
just for a sec
john richard haley bachelor of arts
financial management departmental honors
and financial management
matthew lee van opstel bachelor of arts
financial management
will the graduates in french please come
forward
krista emily phillips bachelor of arts
french
emma kathleen taycatch bachelor of arts
french
heather anne linder bachelor of arts
french and history
francesca taylor crone bachelor of arts
french and german
will the graduates in german please come
forward
vivian elaine hughbanks bachelor of arts
politics in german
magdalena hannah olsen bachelor of arts
german in history
william thomas gage bachelor of arts
german and spanish [ __ ] laude
catherine
catherine rose keane bachelor of arts
german and english
carsten martin stan bachelor of arts
economics and german
magna [ __ ] laude departmental honors and
economics and german
well the graduates in greek please come
forward
history
thank you
okay
sophia
l coyne cosnack bachelor of arts history
magna [ __ ] laude
elizabeth sarah barra bachelor of arts
history
elise luis marie stefke bachelor of arts
history
amanda grace hatch bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude
sheena and alba bachelor of arts history
kristin m berg bachelor of arts history
magna [ __ ] laude
sarah elizabeth rinaldi bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] laude
josiah daniel vega bachelor of arts
history
michaela francis brown bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] laude
jason robert clicker bachelor of arts
history colin thomas moylan bachelor of
arts history
spencer craig scott bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] laude departmental honors
history
andrew john davis bachelor of arts
history
connor james mullen bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude
brian andrew mori bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in history
matthew alan sauer bachelor of arts
history magna [ __ ] laude
graduate of the honors program
tomas antonio valle bachelor of arts
history summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in history graduate of the honors
program
timothy daniel troutner bachelor of arts
history and philosophy summa quade
graduate of the honors program
micah daniel meadowcroft bachelor of
arts history magna [ __ ] laude graduate of
the honors program
madeline elizabeth van der bleek
bachelor of arts history and politics
departmental honors in history
kendall chalene carpack bachelor of arts
history
daniel p negri bachelor of arts history
emily rose peterson bachelor of arts
history [ __ ] laude
michael john marie delora bachelor of
arts history
luke allen adams bachelor of arts
history and politics
mary agnes geiger bachelor of arts
history
elizabeth cheryl mcmanus green bachelor
of arts history magna [ __ ] laude graduate
of the honors program
christina joy lambert bachelor of arts
history summa [ __ ] laude graduate of the
honors program
marie renee wathen
bachelor of arts history
magna [ __ ] laude graduate of the honors
program
salem parker bear bachelor of arts
history
magna [ __ ] laude
will the graduates in international
studies in business and foreign language
please come forward
mitchell d rayer bachelor of arts
international business and foreign
language magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in international business
martha francis maxwell bachelor of arts
international business and foreign
language magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and international business
elizabeth angela picard bachelor of arts
international business and foreign
language magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and international business
will the graduates in marketing please
come forward
justice alan carmey bachelor of arts
marketing and management kumrade
departmental honors and marketing and
management
kayla mitchell wright bachelor of arts
marketing and management [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and marketing and
management
paige and george bachelor of arts
marketing and management
lydia katya ivkovich bachelor of arts
marketing and management
molly thomas grayson's bachelor of arts
marketing and management
kathleen louise burke bachelor of arts
marketing and management
care elizabeth carolyn patard bachelor
of arts marketing management
cheyenna williams bachelor of arts
marketing management
carson rose burt bachelor of arts
marketing management
john desmond bell bachelor of arts
marketing management
elise corrales bachelor of arts
marketing management
janelle ashland beeman bachelor of arts
marketing management departmental honors
and marketing management
thomas joseph kruger bachelor of arts
marketing and management
malin luce brennan bachelor of arts
marketing management
nathaniel ryan knobs bachelor of arts
marketing management
nathaniel lee prigmore bachelor of arts
marketing management
george wallace smith iv bachelor of arts
marketing management
hannah nicole lightner bachelor of arts
marketing management
ashland marie lander bachelor of arts
marketing management magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and marketing and
management
will the graduates in mathematics please
come forward
daniel j garcia bachelor of arts
mathematics
daniel j sloanum bachelor of science
mathematics and philosophy summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in math
graduate of the honors program
amy juliana brenneckmeyer bachelor of
arts mathematics
kaylie ann krushank bachelor of science
economics and mathematics
kyle anthony johnson bachelor of science
mathematics
sarah e cruz bachelor of arts
mathematics
nathan andrew wilson bachelor of science
mathematics
will the graduates in music please come
forward
katrina joy bop
bachelor of arts music departmental
honors in music
ellen faith hogan bachelor of arts music
[ __ ] laude
faith elizabeth liu bachelor of arts
english and music summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and music
grace elise hurts bachelor of arts
music in english summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and music honors
program graduate
taylor hall flowers bachelor of arts
music magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in music
graduate of the honors program
well the graduates in philosophy please
come forward
kristin elizabeth malcolm bachelor of
arts politics and philosophy summa [ __ ]
laude
emma christine smith bachelor of arts
philosophy
the graduate in philosophy and religion
please come forward
william lee shearer bachelor of arts
philosophy and religion
elizabeth catherine thistleton bachelor
of science mathematics and religion [ __ ]
laude
rachel lin blau bachelor of arts
religion
erica diane heimbaud bachelor of arts
religion magna [ __ ] laude
andrew james van der harst bachelor of
arts economics mathematics and religion
summa [ __ ] laude departmental honors and
economics
will the graduates in physical ed please
come forward
alyssa christine jones bachelor of arts
physical education
zachary scott miller bachelor of arts
physical education
physics
well the bachelor for the graduates in
physics please come forward
sarah elizabeth johnson bachelor of
science physics and international
business and foreign language
cody daniel jessup bachelor of science
politics and physics [ __ ] laude
andrew c zeiler bachelor of science
physics [ __ ] laude
will the graduates in political economy
please come forward
nathan gregory scyther bachelor of arts
political economy
anthony caster bachelor of arts
political economy
julianne elizabeth grignol bachelor of
arts political economy
nicholas paul taylor bachelor of arts
political economy
daniel john pittman bachelor of arts
political economy
departmental honors and political
economy [ __ ] laude
matthew robert hazelton bachelor of arts
political economy magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and political
economy
spencer s dohan bachelor of arts
political economy
got a little backup
christie anna allen bachelor of arts
political economy summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors and political
economy
randy james keith bachelor of arts
political economy
megan elizabeth
pradco bachelor of arts political
economy magna [ __ ] laude departmental
honors and political economy
congratulations bailey
bailey elise arlinghaus bachelor of arts
political economy in spanish summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in political
economy and spanish
jesse allegra mathis
bachelor of arts political economy
kumwade departmental honors in political
economy
will the graduates in politics please
come forward
noah donald heiser bachelor of arts
politics
craig thomas llewellyn bachelor of arts
politics
alexis m allen bachelor of arts politics
tyler daniel warman bachelor of arts
politics
dominic a rastuccia bachelor of arts
politics
sarah moreland albers bachelor of arts
politics
hannah gene anderson bachelor of arts
politics
elainey r brandes bachelor of arts
politics summa [ __ ] laude
bachelor of science mathematics and
politics summa [ __ ] laude departmental
honors in math and politics
graduate of the honors program
and class of 2016
valedictorian
emily elizabeth runge
bachelor of arts in politics summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in politics
graduate of the honors program
anna judith seipel bachelor of arts
history and politics
jordan leah finney bachelor of arts
history politics religion and spanish
[ __ ] laude
graduate of the honors program
sergeant michael john avang bachelor of
arts politics kumare
second lieutenant josiah mark lippencott
bachelor of arts politics summa [ __ ]
laude departmental honors in politics
graduate of the honors program
daniel david sunny bachelor of arts
politics [ __ ] laude
graduate of the honors program
austin michael prachko bachelor of arts
politics
samantha eileen fletcher bachelor of
arts politics summa [ __ ] laude
will the graduates in psychology please
come forward
aaron nicole graham bachelor of science
psychology [ __ ] laude departmental honors
in psychology
christopher michael raby bachelor of
arts psychology
xavier michael pennell bachelor of
science psychology
jillian zoe baldwin bachelor of science
psychology magna [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in psychology
lindsay porritt pierce bachelor of
science psychology
elise ann byron bachelor of arts spanish
and psychology summa [ __ ] laude
departmental honors in psychology
emily ann wolfert bachelor of arts
psychology
clayton robert wilbanks bachelor of arts
french and psychology
rebecca grace french bachelor of science
psychology departmental honors in
psychology
antonia lee bush bachelor of science
psychology
ryan john aaron's bachelor of art
politics in spanish magna [ __ ] laude
okay
the graduates in spanish
claire johanna williams bachelor of arts
history in spanish cumwade
marlena marie jackson bachelor of arts
spanish magna [ __ ] laude graduate of the
honors program
andrew huffington beard bachelor of arts
economics and spanish
vincent robert cook bachelor of arts
english and spanish
the graduates in speech please come
forward
thank you
that's okay
hannah abigail
bachelor of arts speech summa [ __ ] laude
and marie cui bachelor of arts speech
claire marie ben's bachelor of arts
speech
bachelor of arts speech departmental
honors
speech alexander warfield eaton bachelor
of arts speech
savannah ray wirenga bachelor of arts
speech
molly eileen ben's bachelor of arts
speech
will the graduates in sports management
please come forward
thank you
jason scott pretzer bachelor of arts
sports management
elizabeth r hopkins bachelor of arts
sports management
bachelor of arts sports management summa
[ __ ] laude
madison elise berry bachelor of arts
sports management
will the graduates in sports psychology
please come forward
garrett lynn jones bachelor of science
sports psychology
well the graduates in theater please
come forward
congratulations
catherine elizabeth coffey bachelor of
arts english and theater kumwade
nicholas ryan gibbs bachelor of science
theater
hold on just a minute
is there anyone remaining whose name has
not been called
in the graduating class of 2016.
on behalf of the faculty in the college
congratulations class of 2016.
professor pastrito will you proceed with
the granting of the master's degrees
will the master of arts graduates in
politics please come forward
second lieutenant daniel edward bieber
united states air force
paula denise briskey
colin michael brown
bruno cortez
peter richard watson cross
captain david nicholas stanford united
states army
tara janae elkins
clifford paul humphrey
jeremy stephen marcelli
moritz peter mucha
nathaniel paul pullman
zachary taylor reynolds
nicholas murad salma
thomas james
takuma
okay
congratulations to our masters graduates
dr arne the awarding of the master's
degrees is complete
on behalf of the board of trustees it
gives me great pleasure to congratulate
you on your years of hard work and
accomplishment here
and of course
on your graduation today
if i may go back some four and a half
years i'd also like to salute you and i
assume in most cases your parents
on your selection of this school
you truly i i may have a bit of bias
but you truly could not have made a
better choice
my guess is that you might have received
an education the quality of which would
roughly equal what you have received
here at but half a dozen other schools
throughout the country
this is an amazing place
and from the
providential dr arn
through these amazing men and women who
have taught you over your four years
here
to the highly capable administrators
and the amazing support staff
this college has
but one major problem in my estimation
it is unique
if this country is to be saved
it will be saved in no small measure
by young men men and women
leaving this place
going forward
to share
what they have learned here
as you as you leave
consider it an obligation that you hold
along with your degree to share the
superior education
and knowledge that you have gotten here
you know things that the bulk of your
contemporaries about the country have no
sense of
you have an appreciation for the
founding of this country
how it was founded why it was founded
and what it's all about
as you whatever you do as you leave here
to form your families and pursue your
careers bear that obligation
in mind share what you have learned here
with the rest of the country we are
obliged i thank all of us here to share
what we know in an effort to try and
save
our once wonderful country
again from the board our warmest
congratulations and our very best wishes
to each of you
for for
very successful
very
wonderful lives
godspeed